[Music]
we all have our favorite toys we love to
play with and we bet most of them are
extremely cute and cuddly but get ready
because these toys are anything but cute
wait until number one to see the
scariest toy we managed to find don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up if you
got scared now get ready because these
are the 15 kids toys that will give you
nightmares creepy clown doll okay
let's start with clowns is there anyone
out there that likes clowns oiz well
after having this one they won't like
them anymore designed for Halloween this
toy is not only creepy it also talks
just push the button and you'll hear the
creepy clown talking to you accompanied
by some carnival music the clown says
things like it loves making babies cry
and encourages people to move a little
closer because it won't bite not to
mention its entire look is absolutely
creepy enough to give you nightmares if
you're looking to scare someone this
creepy clown doll is the way to go being
afraid of clowns is actually connected
to psychology of the human brain so it's
safe to say the stall will definitely
give you some nightmares remote-control
spider what's worse than clowns its
spiders if you know someone that gets
easily afraid of spiders give them the
remote-control spider toy this is one of
the most perfect pranks ever even though
we have to admit it's pretty mean the
remote-control spider toys are pretty
self-explanatory you can find plenty of
spiders out there from simple spiders to
some of the more creepy ones like
tarantulas fake spider toys are scary on
its own but imagine adding the remote
control function have this creepy toy
crawl around your target person and
watch them totally freak out
it's the perfect toy to play a mean
prank on someone but just be careful
because this one really is nightmare
inducing seriously these toys get way
too realistic with every new release
five nights at Freddy's nightmare toys
are often connected to the horror
culture and five nights at Freddy's
definitely belongs there it's one of the
scariest games out there so why not jump
scare someone in real life in case you
didn't know you can actually get 5
nights at freddy's collectible toys
they're only about 3 inches tall but
just imagine this nightmare freddy toy
staring at you when you wake up
nightmares are definitely guaranteed you
can also get any other five nights at
freddy's characters and they're all
equally
scary although this is an extremely cool
concept for fans of the game we have a
feeling it might give unexpected people
some serious nightmares just look at
these scary creatures the only thing
that would make them even cooler would
be the glow-in-the-dark function zombie
Teddy another thing that never gets old
when it comes to giving nightmares is
zombies seriously if you want to scare
someone you give them a zombie toy but
if you want to scar them for life
give them the zombie teddy toy this is a
Halloween product that belongs in the
skeletal plush toy collection and it's
pretty amazing teddy bears are supposed
to be cuddly but this teddy is far from
cuddly just check it out you can see
it's skeleton and it's definitely
looking like it's been through a lot we
can't even imagine a child playing with
anything like this and not getting
nightmares after on the plus side this
teddy bear still looks just as soft and
cuddly which is really really confusing
scary teddy
but if fluffy teddy bears don't scare
you this type of teddy might remember
scary teddy and the duck from The
Nightmare Before Christmas sure it's a
small toy but just look at those faces
some of the design detail is pretty
gruesome but what makes this toy stand
out even more is the fact that it can be
operated remotely just turn it on and
use the remote control to drive it it
makes a terrible screeching sound as it
drives around which really doesn't help
its case at all
play with this around a little kid and
chase them with the toy it's guaranteed
they'll have a few nightmares about
being chased by a scary yellow duck and
a crazy looking cat trust us you will
either freak out other people or you'll
be left with a few nightmares yourself
slime zombie slime is absolutely
everywhere but being this huge trends
that it is you'll naturally see it
turning to something totally disgusting
like this slime zombie this toy has
several designs and they all come with
the same function to throw up slime
inside this toy box you'll also get some
squidgy slime and what you need to do is
squeeze the zombies head and let the
pressure basically vacuum the slime in
its mouth then squeeze its head again
and the slime will come out in true
zombie style
just imagine scaring an unsuspected
victim with a toy like this put the
zombie in front of them and then just
squeeze the head we have a feeling it
will put people off slime and zombies
forever
and if this toy won't do the job the
next one will slime squeeze toys
of all the toys were showing you today
these are probably the cutest well at
least in the way they look and that's
before you use the slime the throw-up
toys are now becoming hugely popular due
to the popularity of the slime trend
what's better than poking and playing
with slime seeing it come out of a toys
mouth now this type of toy throw-up is
much more realistic you get a small
piece of slime and a cute round squishy
toy squeeze its head and watch the slime
come out conveniently the color of the
slime is also yellow then squeeze its
head again and watch it get sucked back
in but not before it leaves some sticky
yellow leftovers around the mouth
seriously if there's a way to end the
slime trend with nightmares
it's these toys creepy unicorn
everyone loves unicorns but do you love
all types of unicorns we don't think so
remember my little pony
the former designer that used to create
these adorable ponies wanting to create
something completely different meet the
creepiest unicorn ever the designer is
clearly channeling her darker side and
it's really working instead of going for
cute unicorns you can get this totally
creepy unicorn called vamp let's sure
it's pink but it's also a monster we
can't imagine a child and join something
like that in case you're not a huge fan
of unicorns this designer featured
several other plushie type vamp --let's
that are all ready to color you at night
or you know give you terrible nightmares
after you realize they're definitely not
what you'd expect would you snuggle up
with a vamp let's let us know in the
comments lifelike Popeye okay now this
is terrifying Popeye the sailorman might
no longer be as popular as he used to be
but we do hope that people still eat
spinach to make sure they're just as
strong as this guy although this
lifelike 12-inch Popeye toy clearly went
a little overboard on its protein intake
just look at him we have a feeling this
toy would give nightmares to plenty of
kids who have never heard of Popeye the
sailorman although just to be fair he
does look like a regular bodybuilder
just add the sailor hat some tattoos and
a pipe and voila you get the ultimate
Popeye toy seriously we all know
tracking macros can make you gain more
muscles but isn't this just a little bit
over the edge for a toy we're telling
you someone out there is going to have
some serious nightmare
tarah heads nope we're still not done
with scary teddy bears
if you thought clowns were scary just
wait until you see this terror Ted's our
custom-made teddy bears made in the UK
an available worldwide the company
features some pretty scary teddy bears
but you can also get creatures like Tiny
Ted's which are well tiny the teddy
bears are fragile and the company's
sakes then it's better to have them
guard your house rather than being a
cutlet toy to be fair they could easily
scare just about anyone just check them
out they're definitely not a toy you
would cuddle just look at it it has eyes
on its paws instead of its head and
that's just one of the many example
designs you can get definitely nightmare
inducing teddy bears rather than cuddly
ones musical jolly chimp this might be
the most terrifying toy you normally see
in horror movies but even so it's not
the most terrifying toy so stay tuned
for number one the musical jolly chimp
aka the symbol banging monkey has an
interesting history that dates back to
the 1950s it was used to buy street
performers to attract people while
making noise let people quickly realized
how creepy it actually is
since then the chimp has been featured
in plenty of horror movies in case
you've never seen it before or know what
it does here's a lowdown it's a battery
operated toy that looks like a monkey
when you turn it on it just bangs it
symbols over and over again combine it
with horror music and you have the
ultimate nightmare inducing toy Little
Miss no-name but no toys do creepy as
well as dolls do unless you own
something like a Barbie doll or an
American Girl doll you're probably
familiar with creepy dolls
Little Miss no-name is one of them this
doll was around in 1965 she was dressed
in a rag and had a single tear on her
face but what made her really creepy was
the fact that she had no eyes it was
supposed to be a doll you take pity on
and take her home because she has no
name but it actually turned out to be
really creepy Hasbro actually stopped
producing these nightmare dolls only
after a year so clearly they were
freaking out way too many people and we
can definitely see why be honest
would you take Little Miss no-name home
baby peed meat baby peed one of the
creepiest toys ever sure this one is a
DIY toy but it's so disturbing
we have to add it in so the way to
create this crazy toy is to get a bunch
of babies and well rip them apart the
way this baby stands on its own is by
having a wire from the top of its head
all the way down to the base legs the
base of the legs also has some concrete
to make it stand that's not really
important because you should be focusing
on the fact that this is a baby
centipede just look how many arms this
thing has it's definitely creepy and we
can imagine quite a few people having
nightmares about this seriously imagine
this baby being real and crawling
towards you no thanks poor zombie bang
but you know what's even worse than a
baby centipede or a cymbal monkey a
zombie that comes out and scares you
like jack-in-the-box when it comes to
scary toys this one definitely wins and
it's not even a toy it's a bank so this
is how this strange thing works you
place a coin on the light blue part of
the box then the box automatically opens
a creepy zombie hand pops out and you
see a scary zombie face for a minute the
box closes again just imagine this
accompanied by horror music and we can
guarantee you'll be getting nightmares
also if you check out the front it reads
that this zombie will hunt them down to
a place opposite from heaven talk about
creepy and scary if you made it this far
in the video make sure to close your
eyes because it's about to get even
scarier terror horror Halloween okay are
you ready you can open your eyes but
only if you're not scared of really
really creepy masks this cosplay toy is
the winner of the kids toys that will
give you nightmares because honestly we
couldn't find anything as scary as this
if your eyes are still closed here's a
brief description of this horrible toy
it's a pig's Mass featuring long dark
hair and a really creepy design this pig
really looks like it's been through
quite a lot now imagine putting this on
your head and scaring someone we bet
they'd be scarred for life this is one
that gives nightmares as well as some
really traumatic memories and out of all
the toys we've shown you today it's
definitely the scariest thing we have
ever seen don't worry you can open your
eyes now it's gone and that's all for
our video what's the scariest toy you've
ever heard of let us know in the
comments thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]